all right so God of War Ragnarok is out
now in the blades of chaos have never
looked better going up against the Norse
pantheon the plumpy Thor and his
Almighty mjolnir what a shocker but in
this video we're going to be briefly
recapping the previous game discuss the
couple different endings are theories
for the next game along with our
reaction and review of this new
installment in the God of War franchise
now let's not waste any time because
Ragnarok is on its way now if you enjoy
this video then Leviathan ax throw at
that like button as it helps the channel
and also don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns reviews and Recaps like this
every day with that out of the way a
huge thank you for clicking this I'm
Jared now let's get into God of War
Ragnarok you seem like a calm and
reasonable person
are you a calm and reasonable person
foreign
[Music]
before we dive into the destruction of
Ragnarok let's go over a brief recap of
the ending of God of War 2018.
essentially the main mission was to
spread FaZe ashes kratos's wife and a
trace's mother on the tallest peak in
all of the nine Realms this happens to
be yodenheim the home of the Giants
along the way atreus and Kratos get into
all sorts of scrambles resulting in a
dead Boulder they made Pebbles of him
which upsets Fria his mother pledging
wrath upon the two of them but if we
fast forward to the ending the pair
discover a mural in yodenheim that
illustrates atreus's life a prophecy of
events of the game thus far revealing
that Faye had been a giant herself named
laufi therefore atreus is half Giant and
half Greek god and that the Giants had
referred to him as Loki surprise but it
has atreus walks away Kratos notice is a
hidden portion of the prophecy depicting
the death of him either by atreus or
with atreus so with it now being
revealed that atreus is the trickster
god Loki the two head back to their home
in the forest with mamir mentioning that
it is the start of thimble winter a
constant ever-growing winter that spans
three Summers leading to the end of
everything AKA Ragnarok there's a final
T stating years later with a big old
Thor showing up to their home either to
talk or to kill them showing off the
gods Almighty Milner before cutting to
Black so um Ragnarok is the event at the
core of this game with it having all you
know obviously been set up by the pair
in God of War 2018. now if you don't
know what Ragnarok is it's a 2017 Marvel
Studios movie where we see wrong Google
search Ragnarok is simply defined as the
final destruction of the world in the
conflict between the ECR and the powers
of Hell led by Loki set three years
after the first game the main goal at
the center of God of War Ragnarok is the
impeding Doom of Destruction on the
horizon while Kratos and atreus must
Traverse the nine Realms Gathering
relics to find a way of stopping it
along their way they meet several allies
like agrabata and tyr the Norse god of
war who all ask atreus who is your daddy
and what does he do while also budding
heads with many prominent members of
Norse lore like heimdell and of course
Thor who seeks revenge on his
half-brother Boulder and his two sons
that Kratos and a train is killed in the
first game all of this leads to the
doorstep of Asgard as Ragnarok
approaches but Odin continues to seek
for an unknown knowledge that he
believes Loki can uncover obviously
trying to exploit him to be used to
prevent the end of everything but the
cycle of vengeance is not so easily
broken now the ending leads Kratos
atreus and the United forces of the
other Realms to begin a full-on assault
Allah you know the portal scene from
Avengers end game on Asgard against Odin
however he had been expecting them with
Valkyries and other Ein Harrier of his
own to stand in their way Kratos and
atreus battle through hordes having
through our joined them with syndry
breaking down the guard wall surrounding
all of Asgard unfortunately tubby Thor
is waiting for them going full on
Rock'em sock'em robots with Kratos
though Kratos bests him and milnar
demanding him to think about the
children that they don't need to be
destroyers they must be better again
tying in with the cycle of Vengeance
that is not so easily broken Thor throws
down mjolnar stating that he won't kill
Kratos or be used for his power again
this results in Odin killing him because
Thor had only been kind of seen as a
tool to him with Odin now fighting
Kratos atreus and Fria it's a damn Jerry
Springer family Throwdown atreyus
smashes the masks that Odin was about to
use to gain the unlimited knowledge
ripping his soul from his body and
placing it in a marble like all of the
giant souls he had discovered along the
way keep been the Odin marble seems like
a terrible Genie in a Bottle situation
instead syndrie angrily smashes it
because of Brock's death by Odin earlier
once again alluding to you guessed it
the cycle of Vengeance ragnacock I mean
a Ragnarok thrusts his giant sword into
Asgard destroying all of it as they
escape the final moments reveal angra
Boda showing atreus one final mural from
Faye revealing she had destroyed the
Shrine in yodenheim so that he and
Kratos wouldn't know their fate instead
allowing them to forge their own to
break the prophecy atreus wants to now
go off on his own to seek out more of
his own story finding more of the giants
that are in hiding obviously heavily
hinting we could get in atreya's
Standalone story in the future Kratos
and him finally part ways in one hell of
a gut punch emotional scene
Loki will go
dress
remains
[Music]
after atreus leaves Kratos discovers
another side of the mural opening it up
to reveal his own story there are
depictions of Athens Kratos with the
blades of chaos traveling on a boat from
there to midgard along with key events
from the first game and this one the
final panel is a second gut punch of
emotion as we see Kratos standing above
wearing his Spartan gear while holding
the Leviathan ax a blend of his past and
present what he was and what he has
become being worshiped as a God after
others argued he was never a true God
because he was never worshiped or prayed
to his journey of becoming a worthy God
is complete one that his people love a
right and just God Freya and mamir ask
Kratos what he saw replying a path I had
never imagined referring to him never
thinking through all of the rage in
turmoil he would become who he is now a
final hint of cleaning up Odin's mess of
the nine Realms is mentioned by Freya as
a bit of post-game content suggesting
Legions of Ein hairier you know the
chromed out Mad Max Fury Road characters
still remain now in the post game
content there is one more ending a
secret ending that is
um secret but it's a funeral for Brock
if you head to spartalheim you can meet
with the dwarves on the shores of the
spurred Saiyans this will see another
emotional send-off of a beloved
character Brock a disheveled syndry
Pace's final respects as Brock is sent
out to see in a traditional Viking
funeral Kratos tries to offer regards to
sindri but bitterly refuses staring him
down as he staggers off and vanishes
once again and I've said it like four
times now don't don't make me repeat
myself but the cycle of vengeance is not
so easily broken as for where potential
follow-ups and spin-offs could go the
ending of Ragnarok leaves a few
breadcrumbs we can follow we could see a
split story following Kratos as he is
now you know kind of become the new God
of War in quotes in a sense for the
Norse pantheon because uh you know tear
well uh he he be dead there were
mentions of Ghana a valkyrie Queen still
lurking out there so she could assemble
some forces storming kratos's doorstep
while the other half of the story seized
Loki now a grown man adventuring his way
to uniting all of the Giants him and
Kratos team up but this results in the
death prophecy that we saw at the end of
2018's God of War though do take
everything with a grain of salt because
Corey barlog said in an interview that
this Norse series would be complete
after two games but hey Money Talks baby
the next series will most likely jump
into a different mythology in general
either bring Kratos back into the mix or
even handing off the blades of chaos to
atreus various interviews suggest Mayan
or Hindi culture and the 2018 game
hinted at Egyptian Greek Celtic and even
Shinto however the Egyptian Pantheon
seems to be the front runner because
that almost became the setting of the
2018 game with concept art being shown
off Egypt was also the setting in the
God of War Fallen God comic run so the
Egyptian story could even bridge the gap
between you know God of War 3 and then
2018 rebukwil but what do you think
where do you want to see the next God of
War be set hell they could even get
wacky with things and set it present day
like the original god of war
post-credits scene remember that that
was wild overall ragnarok's story is
just man it's the sprawling Adventure
steeped in Norse mythology that I was
hoping for the fact that all nine Realms
are open for our Discovery and even more
familiar and unfamiliar members of the
Norse pantheon are present it feels like
the world and story has so much depth to
it I mean who knew I needed to see Thor
in a bar fight acknowledging his
drinking problems this drink I like it
another
atreus coming into his own evolving as a
character on screen plus Kratos learning
to become more calm and understanding
adds that extra layer to everything
though I think the 2018 God of War had
more impactful emotional plot beats
Ragnarok isn't shy of its own moments
and I commend the team for really
developing Kratos into a character that
you can really sympathize with rather
than you know an ending in a traditional
sense like kill everything in sight Rage
of the earlier games like have we ever
seen this man cry before like damn it's
great but I'm not crying I'm not a crier
I don't cry I you know I work out but
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on God of War Ragnarok and what you
thought of this story overall is this
sequel worthy of wielding mjolnir and
I'll let you know we are currently
running the competition giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of November and all you have to do
to get a chance of winning this is like
this video subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment Down Below on God
of War Ragnarok we picked the comments
at random at the end of the month and
the winners of last months are on screen
right now so if that's you message us on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch be sure to check
out some of our other cool videos
whether it be our and or episode 10
ending explained or our full wakanda
forever breakdown with that out of the
way thanks for your constant support
I've been Jared I'll see you in the next
one take care and boy
all right uh peace